Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go to Nick
from Long Island.
Nick, welcome.
Speaker 4: Hey, David.
So my question is, is, um.
Do you think that?
So we had primaries last night.
We had John Fetterman win the Pennsylvania
primary.
And it's looking like conservative Democrat
Kurt Schrader is going to lose this primary
to a more left leaning candidate.
I was wondering, because I've heard many on
the left say that progressive candidates have
a better chance of winning the general election.
Do you agree with that, or do you think that
more moderate candidates have better chances
of winning?
Speaker 1: There's no one answer for that.
So, for example, in West Virginia, if a more
progressive Democrat manages to successfully
primary Joe Manchin, that progressive Democrat
almost certainly loses the election in West
Virginia.
And we get a Republican senator in a place
like Pennsylvania.
I think a more progressive Democrat is far
more likely to do well in the general.
So there's no one answer in order to say who
is likely to do better.
You first have to answer the question, Well,
who's in the electorate are we talking about
nationally?
Are we talking about a particular congressional
district or a state?
Does that make sense?
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Well, doesn't it depend on what policies are
popular in the state we're talking about?
Speaker 1: That's right.
So so to say, are progressives likely to do
better?
The question is, well, who are the voters
and what do they want?
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Um, so it's not like.
It's not like a black and white thing.
Speaker 1: No, not at all.
Not at all.
I mean, there are there are there are seats
where a centrist Democrat is as left as would
be able to win.
There are other seats like, for example, AOC
is district.
AOC replaced a long time incumbent.
She she's well to his left because the electorate
lined up with her views.
You know what I'm saying?
Speaker 4: Yeah, but that's that's like a
safe seat.
That's a safe Democratic seat.
I'm talking about like an mainly swing swing
district.
Speaker 1: Well, it depends on the specifics
of the district, is what I'm saying.
Speaker 4: All right.
Yeah.
And I want to point that out, because I heard
from Dave Wasserman on Twitter saying that
the Cook Political Report will change Oregon's
fifth District to a toss up race if Kurt Schrader
loses his primary to a more.
I forgot the person's name, but.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you.
Okay.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much.
I appreciate the call.
Yeah, not one answer.
That's a it's a great question.
It's a complicated question as well.
Why don't we speak next to, um.
Let's go to.
I hope I pronounce this correctly.
Is it Sakhi Kazi from Pakistan?
Speaker 4: Yeah.
No.
Speaker 5: Sorry.
I say my name was whether I.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, welcome to the show.
Speaker 5: I am a big fan of your show.
I've been watching your videos on YouTube
and they're really interesting.
They took my interest.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 5: So I'm a little.
Guilty here, I guess, or something.
Speaker 1: You're doing great.
What's your question?
What's on your mind?
Speaker 4: I was just thinking and I don't
know if this is.
Speaker 5: Relevant right now or something.
Speaker 4: But I feel like if you had a chance
to say.
At.
Speaker 5: Positives.
I only make controversial or.
Speaker 1: Not, but.
Speaker 4: If you were to get, say, the former.
Speaker 5: President on your show.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
You're talking about Trump.
Speaker 4: No boy.
Hmm.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Your connections.
Your connections gone into the toilet.
Sorry.
I'm going to have to flush the connection
10 to 15 times.
We just.
We're just losing you.
It's.
It's just digital noises.
I apologize.
Let's go to Kyle from South Carolina.
Kyle, welcome.
Kyle from South Carolina, you're on the show.
And last chance for Kyle from South Carolina.
You've got to unmute.
And now I can.
Speaker 4: Hi.
How's it going?
Speaker 1: Good.
Speaker 4: Here's why I was falling is because
I didn't think I'd represent us.
Have you heard anything about it?
Speaker 1: Kyle, I'm sorry.
Are you using speakerphone or something?
You sound like you're under water.
Speaker 4: I'm using my earbuds, recording
earbuds, but I think that's great.
Speaker 1: BERMAN okay.
Your question was about representation.
Dear God.
All right.
We're going to have to move on.
Everything going right?
This was going so well for so long.
Let's try Matthew from Jersey.
Matthew, please save us.
Speaker 5: Hello?
Speaker 1: Oh, my God.
You're not running a lathe in the background,
are you?
Speaker 5: And do you need any.
Do you need me to do something?
Speaker 1: Yes, please.
Run a lathe.
No, I'm kidding.
Go ahead.
What's.
What's going on?
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 5: Well, one thing, of course, that
I've been thinking about is now obviously
this has changed a little bit with last night's
primaries because a lot of left wing people
late one there was some early John Fetterman,
Charles Booker.
I think there was a few in Oregon.
But what I was going to say, thinking about
beforehand was.
You had similar to how you said my whole,
you know, Trump's momentum that was so big
and it went then it starts to go away.
Thank goodness Hawthorn's gone.
And so it made me think, you know, I think
so many of what made me think of Bernie, who
I like a lot by, you know, his name is big
number one spokesman Nina Turner, the symbol
of the left wing movement.
She ran.
She she ran for Congress the first time.
Almost, almost one close call then.
So she runs the second time, gets obliterated
and makes me think is the Bernie factor also
losing its luster?
And furthermore, since Bernie was never president
then, was it ever really there to begin with?
Speaker 1: That's a fair question.
I mean, I've said before, as a Bernie supporter,
I recognize that the perception of Bernie's
level of support was pretty significantly
overstated.
If you spent a lot of time on Twitter and
Reddit relative to the Democratic Party at
large.
I don't know that I would say that that Bernie's
Bernie's losing its luster.
I mean, I think Bernie's not been a major
factor in the last year, I think is what I
think.
Matthew, I have to ask, what is all that noise
in the background?
Speaker 5: You know, I don't I don't hear
any noise.
Speaker 1: It sounds like either a didgeridoo
or a lawnmower.
I'm going to answer the rest of the question
offline, just just so we don't subject our
audience to the torture there.
I think what's going on is that some of these
races, Nina Turner, I think, is a good example.
And I know people get really mad when I make
this analysis.
The electorate in that district, I forget
what number of district in Ohio is just not
as left as maybe it seemed from the national
enthusiasm behind Nina Turner.
It's not an insult, it's not an attack.
It's just the recognition that the people
that voted didn't really seem to be buying
the Nina Turner ideology, what she was selling.
And we just have to recognize it kind of goes
back to the earlier question of it is a progressive
more likely to win?
Well, where in what district and what state
and when, when?
And so I think that there's no one answer
to that question, but it's less about Bernie's
momentum or whatever.
It's you know, there are there are places
where the voters that maybe they're wrong,
maybe they're ignorant, but they prefer something
different than Bernie.
Nina Turner And we all have to just kind of
recognize that and meet people where they
are, at least initially.
And then then you see what changes you can
make.